Senator Ted Cruz is with US senator
welcome to the program well it looks
like all indications will be that this
is going to be a fourth indictment of
President Donald J Trump uh my sources
are telling me that there'll be many
others also likely indicted in this and
perhaps even some unindicted
co-conspirators but I'm getting mixed
signals from a lot of people what are
you hearing and what do you think is
happening right now
well Sean it certainly appears that
we're going to see an indictment from
the grand jury in Georgia that may well
be coming out tonight it could come
within the next hour and and I don't
know what's going to be in it there are
lots of rumors there are allegations of
Rico charges we don't know what's in it
but but you asked what my reaction is
I'm pissed I'm pissed at these over and
over and over again if their indictments
tonight will be the fourth indictment of
Donald Trump this is disgraceful our
country is over 200 years old we have
never once indicted a former president
or a candidate and a leading candidate
for president and this is Joe Biden and
this is the Democrats weaponizing the
justice system because they're afraid of
the voters this is disgraceful it is
wrong and it is a b an abuse of power by
Angry Democrats who have decided the
rule of law doesn't matter to them
anymore let me ask you Senator and so
many Americans feel this way and we're
watching Jim Jordan's house Judiciary
Committee on this you know on on a
weekly basis and their their key
investigation is whether or not our FBI
is been politicized and weaponized
whether the doj has been politicized and
weaponized I think we need to put
emphasis on what you just said never in
our our long history as a country has
this ever happened to a former president
nor has it happened to the chief rival
of a sitting president running for
president uh and yet they not only want
these indictments this now would be the
fourth time history has been made but
they want the trials in the middle of
the caucus the primary and the election
season uh is that as president Trump has
been arguing election interference
of course it is and and the timing is
nakedly political every time more bad
news comes out about Hunter Biden or Joe
Biden you can set a stopwatch within
hours some Clown goes and indicts Donald
Trump again and then all of the all of
the little Lemmings and the media go run
and say Trump trump Trump trump look
last week the house oversight committee
released bank records that showed that
Joe Biden's family and Associates
received over 20 million dollars from
foreign sources while Joe Biden was vice
president so just when he's in office
over 20 million dollars let me ask is
there anything on Earth Sean that Hunter
Biden could do for you that would be
worth 20 million dollars well if you're
a Ukrainian oligarch or a Russian
oligarch I guess so and if you actually
go just after the vice presidency Hunter
Hunter and his family got another eight
million dollars from the Chinese
Communists you know what just happened
last week
last week the statute of limitations ran
on the 8 million dollars that flooded to
the Biden family from the Chinese
Communists you know who let it run David
Weiss the U.S attorney who is
obstructing justice who is blocking an
investigation and what did Merrick
Garland do he named him a special
counsel which is disgraceful as you know
I do a podcast every week verdict with
Ted Cruz today's podcast goes through
why David Weiss's appointment is illegal
it is directly contrary to doj
guidelines that say that it has to be
someone outside of the Department of
Justice Merrick Garland doesn't doesn't
care he's ignoring the law but more
importantly it's supposed to be someone
with Integrity to prosecute and David
Weiss has shown that he's willing to
block prosecution of Hunter to allow the
statute of limitations to go forward and
to allow apparatchics on his staff to
protect Joe Biden to say no questions
about the big guy no questions about Joe
Biden it's why you've seen two senior
IRS career whistleblowers come for
forward and it's why I believe we're
seeing an indictment likely tonight
because the media wants to change the
topic I have a couple more questions
Senator I just want to bring people up
to speed at home the Fulton County
District Attorney's Office uh is has now
handed a grand jury indictment to judge
Robert McBurney as we saw just moments
ago the judge looked through the
multi-page document handing it off to
the clerk's office representative we do
expect that now that the grand jury has
handed up this sealed indictment we will
find out what is in at some point
tonight one other point about about Mr
Weiss who's now been you know remember
he was the one that gave Hunter Biden
the sweetheart deal Senator and it was
the sweetheart of all sweetheart deals
and it was a get out of jail free on
anything else that he might have done
you mentioned the statute of limitations
we had already known that on previous
charges we also heard from
whistleblowers that were accusing both
David Weiss and the Attorney General of
telling a very different story about the
real Authority that that Mr Weiss had
whether or not he had Authority in other
jurisdictions it turned out that in fact
he was telling the IRS whistleblowers
that he was telling them he did not have
that Authority so either the
whistleblowers were lying or mayor
Garland and David weiserline I know who
I tend to believe
yeah so so listen Sean I'm right now I'm
back in Texas I'm here with Incredible
Patriots at the Kingwood tea party and
I'll tell you I am in a room with
hundreds of Texans right now who want to
see accountability who want to see the
rule of law who are ticked off that the
president of the United States there is
now growing and and overwhelming
evidence that Joe Biden has made a
business out of selling favors Hunter
Biden was the salesman and let's be
clear it's not access it's not the
appearance of access what the
allegations from the whistleblowers what
the allegation in the FBI FD 1023 are
are that Hunter Biden sold official
favors from Daddy from Joe Biden that is
bribery and bribery is explicitly
enumerated in the Constitution as a
basis for impeachment and instead of
this circus and Sideshow of indictment
after indictment after indictment of
Donald Trump I believe the House of
Representatives needs to move forward
with an impeachment inquiry for Joe
Biden and if it's proven that he
accepted a bribe he should be impeached
he should be removed from office he
should be indicted he should be
prosecuted and he should go to prison
now let's get your reaction to this News
NBC reporting that Fulton County Grand
Jury has returned 10 indictments we are
awaiting the names and the details and
we obviously we we have to believe that
one of them would be president Donald
Trump uh then I I if I had to render a
guess one has to wonder uh if Rudy
giuliani's name would be in there or
Sydney Powell's name would be in there
John Eastman's name would be in there
again I'm only guessing but if I had to
give a educated guess I would say those
are the obvious your thoughts
yeah look I the the one that that is
obvious that it's going to be is Donald
J Trump because it is clear that this
prosecutor went in with an objective to
indict Donald Trump it's the same thing
as Alvin Bragg the wild George Soros
partisan in New York it's the same thing
as Merrick Garland and Jack Smith and by
the way Jack Smith has a history of
bringing partisan indictments he
indicted Bob McDonnell the sitting
governor of Virginia when he was a
credible candidate for president he got
a conviction and that conviction went to
the U.S Supreme Court and it got
unanimously thrown out but the
conviction was all about politics what
they want to do is they want a trial to
attack Donald Trump they'd like a trial
in September or October of next year
right before the election the other 10
people I'm not going to speculate or the
other nine will find out but frankly
there were nine people who were unlucky
enough to be standing somewhere in or
around Donald Trump their target is
political this is not the rule of law
this is not enforcing the law rarely
this is because partisan Democrats have
convinced themselves look if you
disagree with Donald Trump campaign
against him that's called democracy but
Democrats don't believe in democracy
because they're worried the voters don't
want four more years of the disaster
that is Joe Biden and so they want to
abuse the justice system to try to take
that choice away from the voters I I
think that's shameful
all right Senator Ted Cruz has
graciously agreed to stick around with
us as news develops tonight Senator we
really appreciate it your expertise is
needed on a night like tonight hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else